yeah like clockwork Furious progressives
and the media well they're trying to
ensure that your Thanksgiving becomes a
Battleground they want to turn your
humble turkey talk into a full-fledged
political Smackdown the amazing New York
Times running this piece from a
psychologist which encourages liberals
to confront Politically Incorrect family
members at the dinner table my mama
would not allow it and check out this
headline from the nation which says
quote should America keep celebrating
Thanksgiving
apparently we need to decolonize the
turkey feast and replace it with a truce
giving uh Greg would you celebrate truth
giving where basically you sit around
talk about how horrible America is isn't
that what we do now yes you know I
believe this is now part of the
Thanksgiving tradition which is to
protest the Thanksgiving tradition it's
a new layer of Customs that we can
discuss as opposed to the food the
family the weather patterns it sure
beats the traffic reports but there's
one thing that people have to remember
colonizer is now a racist term cuz
what's it mean if I call you a colonizer
what does that mean it means you're
white right yeah so de colonizer black
ones I know a few black oh do you yeah
let me write that down I'll get some
names for you but so if you're going to
decolonize I don't know I mean it's like
it's basically you're talking about the
removal of people who have the stain of
some kind of
lineage uh it's a nice way of saying
cracker so I think from now on Joey when
I see you I'm gonna say what's up my
colonizer Dana I feel like Thanksgiving
I'm going right past that by way God
yeah real quick I feel like Thanksgiving
has had the ability to evolve in this
country we're kind of unique and that we
can celebrate Christmas with Santa Claus
but also remember the reason does
Thanksgiving have to be a history lesson
no so like you know how uh what's your
name Harold he was um he was talking
about how every year they seem surprised
that there's traffic but every year we
see these same stories from Liberal
Publications it's like the old Tickler
fil it's like oh it's becoming November
15th let's assign some stories about how
horrible Thanksgiving is but God meant
for us to be joyful and one of the
things we have done is we figured out
Traditions that give you a chance here's
the key to having a wonderful
Thanksgiving do not invite anybody who
works for the nation and you'll be all
set absolutely Harold you understand the
way these people think I don't how do
you Cate
thanks I I don't
understand my colonizer I don't
know I think that uh anybody that gets
to these days as soon as people as if
see people sit around your table and
want to want to have these kind of cover
just say bless your heart move on and
get the potato or something pass I I had
the the great pleasure Joy last year of
having a few of the people around this
table of Thanksgiving uh and might even
have one of them this Thanksgiving and
all we do is laugh and tell stories and
uh I don't think we talk politics if we
do we don't even know we're talking I
don't understand I've never talked
politics Thanksgiving judge I want to
show you a tweet real quick this is from
UK paa I know you love animals but they
wanted to make sure that the Americans
understand as we celebrate this American
holiday that turkeys don't want to be
eaten I think it's okay to eat a turkey
you know what I I don't even want to
talk about that let me tell you
something you if people want to come to
my house and they don't like America I'm
not cooking for you you can leave that's
the end of it I work too hard now you
know what they say that we shouldn't be
thankful for Thanksgiving because we're
all colonizers and we should tell the
truth of what we've done does anyone in
this country not think that the Native
Americans that the the native
indian-americans
were weren't here first we all know that
we all admit to it they were here first
you can watch any cowboy movie they were
here first
okay this segment is epic okay and you
know what the unfair part of it is that
a lot of them live on tribal lands which
are not as nice as they should be I mean
no one has lied about that so get over
it I just want to let ukpa know I'm
going to eat a flightless bird for every
sentence that said turkeys don't want to
be eaten the fastest is up next hey
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else